So thanks, everyone in attendance. This is a new tract.
This is the first-ever young adult cancer
survivorship tract at
the AACR, and I guess the hope from the AACR is that we can
bring more science to this patient population and
also more emphasis on survivorship.
So I think we're here,
I would say, for one challenging reason and one good reason.
I think the challenging reason is that we're seeing an increase in
certain types of cancer in young onset populations, and the cause of that is
unknown, and Kathy Yang is going to lead us off on that.
The good reason we're here is that we're doing better with cancer treatment and
patients are-- We're seeing more cures, and that's leading
to issues later on, and that's where the survivorship aspect
of this session comes in. And then I'm going to finish it off by talking a little
bit about how we're trying to leverage our large-scale genomics and
sort of discovery efforts pan-cancer to help rare cancer
populations, in terms of new drug development.
So I'm going to hand it off to Kathy, who's going to kick us off from Vanderbilt,
and look forward to your talk.
Thank you so much for inviting me.
It's my sincere pleasure here to-- I'd like to thank the organizers.
It's my sincere pleasure to be here in San Diego.
It's a beautiful city, and I have not been invited back to AACR for about 10
years plus, so I'm delighted to be here.
Okay, today we're going to be discussing just a little bit of broad overview,
focusing on early-onset colorectal cancer and just keeping in mind that the
majority of cases are sporadic and the exact etiology
remains an area of continued investigation.
I really want to highlight that this is an era of insight and intervention,
and it's really based upon what can we offer our patients today, pending
determining the exact etiology for early-onset colorectal cancer.
Our patients are seeking... So sorry, I'm going to take off my glasses.
Our patients are seeking more autonomy, a deeper understanding, and more
options in regards to their treatment.
And we've learned, actually, that treatment can vary depending upon the
anatomic location. The sequence of therapy may be impacted, dose
intensification is being considered, nutrition may have an impact, and
then creating treatment infrastructure is important.
So it's really an opportunity for discovery and for
research initiatives. I am a clinical researcher, for those that don't
know me, and so I really want to make sure to provide a perspective for
those that are not necessarily involved directly in patient care.
This really gives you an idea of some of the faces that
have early-onset colorectal cancer.
Unfortunately, many of these patients,
except for a couple of them, have passed away.
They were all sporadic colorectal cancer patients.
Permission was provided. They were all in their 30s and 40s when they were
originally diagnosed.
And basically, these were parents.
They had full-time jobs.
The woman on the,
sorry
the second one here, she was training for a marathon when I met
her. He was a lawyer. She was a teacher.
Sorry. She was a teacher. She worked in the healthcare industry.
He's a veteran.
And he owned a
farm for several years and breeds cattle.
And I never thought over all these years that I would be still talking
about why we don't know the exact etiology for early-onset colorectal
cancer. And I never thought I would be doing congressional briefings for years
'24 and 2026, actually this year.
So to give you a perspective for average age patients, these are the numbers
for 2025. This data has not been updated on the website, and that's why I showed
this to you. But it's important to keep in mind that the average age patient in the
United States is 66 at this time. And despite
the knowing the fact that colorectal cancer is important for screening with
colonoscopies, we still expect a rise by
2040 based upon GLOBOCAN.
What will happen in 2026?
Well, it's going to be about 159,000 patients will be diagnosed.
The mortality is going to be about 56,000, and about 16% of
those patients are going to be early-onset patients.
And when we say early-onset, we refer to 50 years of age, less than 50 years of
age.
This is about a 3% increase per year, and I want to highlight this article from
Rebecca Siegel,
and that's about 50 cases per day. And globally, that's
450 to 600 cases per day.
Where is this happening anatomically?
These are
early-onset patients historically.
Once again, the majority that I see are sporadic, and it's largely
happening in the distal colon, so from the rectum
and sigmoid colon and as well as the descending colon.
And that's important to keep in mind because I'm going to be talking about
treatment.
This literature that I mentioned from Rebecca Siegel, sadly, we had
decided originally that in 2030, early onset may
be at risk for being the leading cause of mortality.
But unfortunately, by her publication in this January, it is now the leading
cause of mortality as of 2023, and that's why
we're here to have further discussion.
We know that geographically there is variability.
On the left is a graph of the United States, originally from 2001 to
2007, then increased by 1.27% for early onset.
If you look at the West Coast, that has dramatically increased.
And then if you look at the bottom panel, it's increased by three times
that from the duration from 2011 to 2017, and it's
also a global issue. These were some of the countries that have
highlighted based upon each standardized incident rate.
And I visited Seoul, Korea, recently, and unfortunately, it is the leading cause of
early onset in Asia at this time.We also have
data regarding birth cohort analysis. You've seen this data before from Dr.
Stoffel, which was heavily cited.
Twofold higher risk if you're born after 1990 versus 1960 for
colon cancer, and fourfold higher risk for rectal carcinoma.
However, this has also been validated in a recent JNCI publication looking at
England, the UK, Australia, Canada, and the US.
Four times higher risk, once again, if you're born 1990 and
afterwards versus 1960.
There's a lot of ongoing efforts, as many of you are aware of, regarding looking at
the exposome and other aspects that are focused on long-term
projects. We are well aware of the Cancer Grand Challenges.
Andy Chan and Yunsung Kau are leading those efforts.
And then most recently, there are five new teams have been awarded the Cancer
Grand Challenges. So these are amazing efforts, and I look forward to looking at
that data when it's finally ready and available for publication and
presentation. But what can we do for our patients currently?
What is our current state of knowledge, and how do we apply this current state of
knowledge for shared decision-making with our patients and to support research
efforts?
This is basically what I'm seeing in my clinic, and I'm just not going to go into
significant detail, but this is a young woman, this is what I commonly see in my
clinic, with stage IV disease. She has surgically unresectable disease
because those are multiple lung mets, and she has liver mets.
And if you are unaware, for a patient with stage IV disease that is
MSI stable, so sporadic colorectal cancer, the five-year
survival is about 16%. And these patients will
remain on therapy indefinitely.
And then you have the other case of the patient with rectal cancer, and as
mentioned earlier, that's what we're seeing in our early-onset patients.
And this is a patient that we're treating with curative intent.
But then we have to think about where is this location in the rectum,
how that impacts our decision-making aspects in regards to
consideration of radiation therapy, and where do we consider
surgery in this case as well.
So when you're a young patient, these are some of the common thoughts that come
to mind. And these are quotes that I've heard from patients before, and I created
this little cartoon, and I presented this before at ASCO last year.
But they're basically overwhelmed because there's so much that they are dealing
with. These are very different aspects of what they're trying to
accomplish versus our average-age patients.
And we don't know the exact etiology to account for early-onset colorectal
cancer. This was created with the assistance of an AI platform.
And basically, we have multiple studies that have been published regarding
genetic susceptibility. There are some patients, once again, that
they may not know they have a family history, but then they determine that they end
up having a family history, and that can be quite helpful in regards to the fact if
they're MSI high and if they have a history, potentially, of Lynch syndrome.
We know there's lifestyle and behavioral factors regarding dietary intake,
sedentary behavior, diet, and nutrition.
I know yesterday's talk was focused on, there was a talk on obesity
and GLP-1 inhibitors. There's a lot of discussion regarding
gut microbiome. And environmental exposure is a very hot
topic right now. And then obviously, some patients are more prone,
such as those with IBD, metabolic syndromes, obesity
once again, diabetes, et cetera. But we don't have an exact
etiology to account for all this. These are multiple factors that we are
aware of that put our patient at risk, but we do not have a definitive
exact reason why this is happening.
Now, I used to think that there was a molecular alteration to account for all of
this, and I was very naive when I was starting out my career.
But these are four large data sets.
The top is the one with Chris Liu, looking at foundation of medicine.
The bottom one beneath that is looking at data from Tempus.
On the upper right-hand side, that's data from MSK, from Andrea Cercek's group.
And the bottom below is the data that we did with Signatera.
Basically, there's no definitive molecular alterations that
are specific to early-onset patients versus average age onset patients.
So what do we do? We need to focus on how we can help our patients and
how we can evaluate opportunities for research to help them
currently while they're going through this process for their
treatment and after treatment. One of the major things I want to point out early
on, it's very important to discuss with them fertility.
And fertility preservation is often not discussed.
And unfortunately, in the United States, we only have 25 states, which has actually
improved versus 2024, which was 19 states, that have
fertility laws to cover
fertility counseling and help our patients as
best as possible. Now, I put this new publication on the right
called, this really caught my eyes, "Nobody Told Me." It's a small study
doing Zoom calls over seven academic centers.
It's a very small analysis, but at the end of the day, basically what they noted
is that many patients felt these issues were not addressed by their clinicians
regarding fertility, sexual function, body image,
incontinence, pain, and infertility, and
intimacy.
So it's an area ripe for research and development.
This is another pooled analysis, basically looking at over 2,000 patients, and
once again, very similar. Here, sexual dysfunction amongst early-onset
patients, and sexual dysfunction was reported in about 58% of
men, and in females, 36%. In smaller studies, I've seen much higher numbers.
Pain was reported up to 31% of patients, and anxiety/depression was up to
70% of patients. This is important to keep in mind.
Now, I say all this because I mentioned to you earlier, the anatomic location that
we commonly see for our early-onset patients is rectal cancer for our
MSI stable patients. And why is that important?
Rectal cancer is a multidisciplinary treatment modality, so it
involves our surgeons, our radiation oncologists, and our medical oncologists in
plan decision-making with the patient. Why is that important?
Because there's actually a difference that you can make in your treatment
strategy depending upon where your tumor lies in the
rectumAnd our rectum can be anywhere from 12 to
15 centimeters in length. If you have a high-lying tumor, we now
know that there is data that suggests that if you don't have T4 disease, if you
don't have N2 disease, you may consider omitting radiation therapy.
And that's really important for patients, so you can avoid the chronic toxicities
associated with radiation treatment.
That's based upon the PROSPECT data.
But we don't have any data about non-operative management if you omit
radiation therapy, because when that trial was created, that was not one of their
objectives. For low-lying tumors, we have to think about
the sequence of therapy. And we know chemoradiation therapy first for
low-lying tumors is key, and it also allows non-operative
management. But then you are also providing the patient concurrent chemoradiation
therapy to provide them non-operative management.
And so that also obviously puts the patient at risk for toxicities associated with
radiation treatment and potential low anterior resection syndrome.
So this is really a discussion with the patient, and it's really
another significant area for potential research development.
Now, there's also a lot of interest in early onset.
Should we be giving them stronger therapy? Is dose intensification important?
This is not specific to early onset examples I'm showing here, but at the
top is the recent data report from GNT regarding the use of
circulating tumor DNA and dose intensification with adjuvant folfoxiri rather
than just adjuvant folfox. And unfortunately, that trial was negative.
We have data pending for our rectal cancer trial called the JANUS trial, which is
looking at dose intensification with folfoxiri in this setting.
So it'll be interesting to see what those results show.
And as you can guess, I'm sure a large majority of the patients are going to be
early onset patients.
We also have pending data. I apologize.
I had a horrible cold a couple of weeks ago, so my voice is not 100%, so I'm so
sorry. We have pending data from CIRCULATE-US, which is still
enrolling patients, looking at the role of circulating tumor DNA as well, and dose
intensification as well, based upon your circulating tumor DNA and being randomized
to folfoxiri in that setting.
There's a lot of interest in the microbiome, a lot of interest, obviously,
in the homeostatic environment. We need our obligate anaerobes to maintain our
environment, but then we can develop dysbiosis due to various
reasons, antibiotic use, and other factors.
There's a lot of interest in microbiome work.
I just show you some data that came out from the MD Anderson group, a very small
cohort of patients looking at adjacent normal tissue and microbiome
there versus
the microbiome in the tumor itself.
And this is looking at, I think it was 35 samples of early onset versus
average age onset patients overall. It's very interesting.
Once again, a small number of patients.
And everyone has seen this data, I know previously.
It's been cited very heavily from the Diaz-Guay group looking
at the Colobactin microbiome signature, which looked at
132 early onset cases over 11 countries.
The countries do not include the US or the UK, so it's a very select
number of countries that were included, but it was three times higher
signature for SBS88 and ID18
for those that were less than 40 years of age relative to those greater than 70
years of age.
And so this was also associated with the APC driver
mutation. So this needs to be validated further, and a larger
geographic
variability would be appreciated.
I used to think because patients always ask me, "Probiotics?" Well, that seems to
be something that would not be harmful.
That should be something very reasonable to consider.
And then we
had Jen Wargo come in from MD Anderson to Vanderbilt to give a talk
recently, and then she kind of flipped my decision regarding the
applicability of probiotics. So there's the data for
probiotics, a little bit all over the place.
There's data that suggests it's helpful for chemotherapy nausea and diarrhea
in colorectal cancer and lung cancer.
But then, in her data from melanoma looking at IO
therapy, it appears to be potentially negatively impacting the outcomes of
patients that receive IO therapy.
So I think that's just another area that might be quite interesting.
And so these are all the things that patients are thinking about and how they want
to incorporate them and to make their treatment better, to improve their overall
survival. So we have to think about these things now.
I just want to highlight the session from yesterday.
If you missed it, I thought it was a great session, and it should be available
through the virtual meeting regarding obesity and the use of
GLP-1 agonists. We have a lot of data already that says obesity is
associated with your risk of
cancer and decreasing your
progression-free survival and disease-free survival.
And this literature in Jama Open is not new, but it's really highlighted on the
session from yesterday.
We now also realize exercise instead of other therapeutic involvements, instead of
treatment approaches, we can think about exercise such as the CHALLENGE trial,
which really caught all of our attention at ASCO.
And this is really looking, and it's not specific to early onset, once again, but
these patients are motivated to think about these things.
This is a controlled environment looking at structured
exercise versus health education group, and basically
involved 55 centers, a median follow-up of eight years.
There was improvement in disease-free survival and overall survival with structured
exercise. And I thought this was a great paper out of the Canadian group.
We also have data looking at PIC3CA.
So once again, these are all things patients are asking me, "What can I do to
reduce my risk of recurrence?" And normally, we don't order NGS testing in
early-stage disease, but the ALASKA trial looked at colon and rectal cancer
patients stage one and three. They
were not required to undergo adjuvant therapy, and they were subjected to
aspirin
in a randomized study of 160 milligrams daily for three years.
And this really,
a lot of patients were very, very interested in this.
This seems very benign to them to be able to include as part of
their
treatment. And basically now they're requesting this
option.I do want to highlight, we don't have a
lot of information regarding outcomes in early-onset.
The literature is a little bit all over the place, I have to admit.
But I did want to bring this up because I think this is extremely important.
So the BRAF V600E mutation is a well-known mutation, and it's
about 10% of all of our colorectal cancer patients.
And we recently had a new FDA indication with the use of chemotherapy
plus encorafenib, which is a BRAF inhibitor, and cetuximab, which is an
EGFR inhibitor. And that's significantly improved the median
survival of 30.3 months. We did a post hoc analysis of this BreakWater
trial. This was a poster at last year's
ASCO, and we're exploring this further.
And I want to look at the survival of these early-onset patients.
And sadly, the survival for the average-age patients was still
30.3 months. The early-onset patients was 23.8 months,
and we don't know why that is. And so that really tells us that we
really need to still think and identify why this is happening with this patient
population and what can we do to help improve their overall survival.
So there's a lot that needs to still be explored.
So why focus on early-onset once again?
There's so
many aspects, rising incidence, uncertain etiology.
It's a unique burden for patients in general, but we can't
wait to identify exactly why this is happening.
And so this is why I'm providing to you these other options to consider
research in so you can provide
meaningful impact to these patients while they're waiting to determine
exactly all these other large grants that have been
provided that are long-term projects.
And also, we need to provide these cancer support
programs to provide support for these patients.
And really, this infrastructure is incredibly important for these patients.
So these are just some aspects that I think are important for a comprehensive
support program for our early-onset patients, focused on psychosocial
support, navigation, having a nurse navigator, fertility,
nutrition, survivorship, which will be highlighted on in a little bit,
and then obviously integration with research.
Since we created our early-onset program, I just wanted you to be aware, we started
in 2019. Our numbers, at least in 2024,
have risen by 58% of the number of new patients we are seeing across our entire
cancer center.
So it's definitely an unmet need.
And this is what we provide to patients, basically a monthly newsletter and
educational aspects. We just want them to remember that education
is very, very important. Colorectal cancer screening is important, and we are
also recognized that it's important for us as physicians to continue to
educate others. So, because of that, you've seen that
other countries are now changing their screening age as well because they're
learning more about early-onset.
So this is the change in screening age in the UAE and Egypt, which I think is
fantastic.
The numbers are improving overall for screening in the United States, and actually
Korea, they made it a campaign, and they've increased their screening by
75% because they recognize this is a problem.
So this is my colleagues for our early-onset program.
We're having our second symposium November 14th.
It's my nurse navigator and our program manager.
And then these are some of the efforts as a group that
people are doing for ongoing research at this time.
We've created a young adult cancers consortium involving these cancer centers.
It's really an ability to reduce the redundancy, improve development
and mentorship, promote equity and geographic representation in research, and
hopefully improve efficiency of
efforts
and improve our high-impact grantsmanship and publications.
So these are the various institutions I work with.
And then, I wanted to also add that Fight CRC has put together a global think
tank to focus on early-onset. Ninety-eight members over
24 countries, and these are the various subgroups that have been put together
that is ongoing for the next year and a half.
There's also a dedicated focus of various journals, and then there's various
conferences, including AACR last year, which put together a conference
in Canada.
So it's an opportunity for discovery.
Sorry, my voice is going out, but I just wanted to tell you,
I want people to remember our early-onset patients need our help
and really try to focus on what we can do to create research
projects, to focus on what we can do to focus on them
today. So early-onset cancer demands a paradigm shift towards
personalization. Tumor location could be a key.
The lack of unique molecular signature precludes definitive therapeutic
trials with pharmaceutical companies.
Intensification continues to be explored, and microbiome continues to be explored.
Creation and infrastructure support for early-onset programs are encouraged, and
there's multiple opportunities for research development.
And please empower your patients as partners in your cancer research.
And there's my contact information. And thank you so much for your attention.
Okay, so I don't know if there's any questions from the audience.
I'll at least ask,
sort of the year landmark thing where it starts going up in 1990, what
is the speculation for this? Is it dietary?
Is it in utero exposure? Is it environmental?
Does anyone know?
Obviously, I think we think it's probably multiple aspects of that.
We don't know exactly what happened in 1990, per se.
And the fact that it was validated,
not only outside the US, but in the UK, Australia, et cetera, so it just
indicates the birth cohort is a real effect. But we don't know.
Yeah.
And do you actually treat patients differently if they're young, or you're still
just adopting your standard therapies from-
No. Yeah, that's why I put that at the very end, because we cannot
create therapeutic trials specific to early-onset patients because we have not
identified a different molecular signature to suggest to pharmaceutical
companies and the NCI that we need to change our clinical trials based upon
therapeutic options for them.
Okay, great. Do we have a question? Yeah.
Thank you for a very nice talk summary.
Thank you.
I thought that there was some literature that the GWAS polygenic
risk scores were further enriched in the young population. Is that true?
And if so, is there any thought of what that might be telling us
or-
So, I'm so sorry.
So at least based upon all the larger data sets have been
created, there's nothing specifically that's been identified.
There's been hints in some studies, but nothing specifically.
It's a mystery.
Okay.
So, I'm going to move on to the second talk, which is
Goali Mustafi, I think I'm pronouncing it correctly, from
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia, who's a real expert on survivorship.
And I heard her speak at an ASCO event about a year and a half ago, and was kind of
blown away as someone
who has had experience with young onset patients.
And
we definitely need more survivorship research and
investigation, and I'm just honored that she came here for ACR to
give this talk, so come on up.
So thank you very much, David. I just wanted to thank the organizers for the
conference. It's certainly nice to actually see a session
on survivorship at ACR. It was one of the first things that I called a former
mentor of mine to say, "I don't know really what to say at ACR
about survivorship." So I do appreciate the invite.
I will confess, because I want to make sure you know what you're getting yourself
into, that in addition to being a pediatric oncologist, I also am a
pediatric endocrinologist. So that
perspective is something that I incorporate not only in how I approach
and treat patients, but also how I try to persuade everyone
else to believe what I'm
passing along. So I've been tasked to really bring
the world of precision medicine as a framework for survivorship.
So hopefully over the next 20 minutes or so, I can
persuade you as well that we need to change our framework and approach to
survivorship. But before I start, I don't have any
disclosures.
And so as a pediatric oncologist standing here, I will say that the story of
pediatric oncology is truly a story of success.
And as you can see here, and particularly within the past, I would say two
decades, we've really seen
significant advancements in therapy, and whether that's with precision
medicine or risk stratified therapy,
immunotherapy, what we've seen is a significant improvement
in the benchmark that we really use as success, and that is the
five-year overall survival. Over 85% of children right
now diagnosed with malignancy in the United States will be
considered meeting that milestone, which is the five-year overall
survival. And by the SEER estimates in essentially by
2040, we will have an estimated
580,000 childhood cancer survivors.
But unfortunately, the story of this success comes with a huge
price tag, and that price tag is the cumulative burden
of chronic health conditions that our survivors will face.
So nine out of 10 childhood cancer survivors actually diagnosed with a
chronic health condition, and often these chronic health conditions can be
debilitating, life-threatening, and actually lifelong.
And so it really begs for us to step back and think whether
that metric of five-year overall survival is the appropriate
metric to use because it really questions the
quality of that cure.
The other challenge, and I think what's important to recognize about these chronic
health care conditions, is that there is a variation in the
latency of presentation, and some of these can present as
early as at the time of the cancer diagnosis, and a lot of this work,
I put up Dr. Bhadia's picture there. I think Dr.
Bhadia is one of the leaders in the field of survivorship.
But as a pediatric endocrinologist, that's definitely an area that I
see a lot of pediatric patients will have presentation and
manifestations of their endocrinopathies as early as within the first
few years of the cancer diagnosis, but that's really not the end.
And as these patients age, they will continue to have
cumulative presentations of other endocrinopathies.
So I think that that really is another reason why survivorship care is important,
because it crosses that arc lifespan from pediatric to adulthood,
and it further highlights the importance of transition and the
knowledge base that we have to bring to our survivors once they transition
to adult care.
So I adopted this slide from Dr. Les Robison and Smita Bhadia.
So Les Robison recently retired. He was an epidemiologist who I think has
done tremendous
research in the field of pediatric cancer survivorship.
And what really this slide shows is a paradigm of research that we have
used in survivorship. And if you focus on the right
side aspect of this slide, what we've really done in the past few decades is
to harness epidemiology and biostatistics to really through
observational studies, establish that risk association between
exposure and outcome. And so we have built cohorts, and through
that, we've then been able to provide evidence-based care
guidelines, develop risk prediction models,
describe the trajectory of those chronic healthcare conditions.
I think of Dr. Kevin Effinger's seminal paper in "New England
Journal"
in 2004, where he really put the trajectory or just the
importance of chronic healthcare conditions and survivors on the map.
And that also importantly to describe how these health conditions
affect health-related quality of life.
But we're reaching, to me, a time point where we need to really bring
all this data together and start incorporating that into
mechanistic studies to really ask the why and the
how of the survivorship, the biology of survivorship, and I think that this is
where we really have room to make difference in terms of how we approach research,
and ultimately for those to lead to implementation of clinical trials
where we can use that mechanistic knowledge, to essentially have
either preventionOf these late effects after the exposure has
happened, so that's called secondary prevention, or actually try to
prevent a lot of those late effects from occurring by
primary prevention. So I think that that really, to me, is where we
should shift the paradigm and focus from the direction of research in this
population.
So for the rest of this presentation, the way I want to kind of make sure that
I make my case is just to really give you a little bit of background of genetics
and survivorship, and for that, I'm going to focus on cardiomyopathy.
Cardiovascular outcomes in
the chronic health condition realm is the number one morbidity and mortality,
importantly mortality,
that our patients face. So I think that that's helpful to have a better
understanding of that. And then this is where I'm going to shift to being an
endocrinologist and really try to persuade the oncologists in this
audience to care about
endocrinopathies like diabetes mellitus, which really can have a whole host of
other consequences for our patients.
And a topic that really has not received adequate attention is primary
ovarian insufficiency. So we really focus on gonadotoxicity with respect
to fertility, but the lack of hormones, particularly in female survivors,
really has life-lasting consequences.
And then I'm going to switch to giving you a little bit of a framework for how can
we think about survivorship with a biological approach, and that is looking
at epigenetics of accelerated aging.
And finally, I would like to
offer a new model of what I call redefining survivorship from 2.0 to
3.0.
So I think to start this, we really need to step back and
redefine our endpoints, especially if we want to kind of bring a new
lens to the field of survivorship.
Remember earlier I said that the metric that we achieve or try to strive to
achieve is the five-year overall survival,
but survival is not equivalent to survivorship.
I think that that's an important concept to recognize, because surviving
your cancer alone does not mean that you actually have full
recovery. So we do know, especially as you care for these patients, there's
a heterogeneity in outcomes. And currently, the way our system is
set up, we really have some gaps in care.
What we do is a lot of reactive care.
You just basically do organ-based screening, and once you find an abnormality, then
you address that. Our care guidelines are very
generalized. They're not prescripted.
They're not patient-centered, so they're not really personalized.
And so despite these being some obstacles, I think it actually presents wonderful
opportunities for us to actually look at these as ways to
integrate more longitudinal clinical data.
I think this is where it's important to have structured data elements across
institutions where we can really harmonize and bring the data together,
and really an opportunity for us to kind of incorporate molecular and genomic
profiling for real-world evidence to give us an approach for
risk stratified precision survivorship care.
So I think to just start off with cardiomyopathy, again, as the oncologists in
this audience, I don't need to
remind you that anthracycline chemotherapy is a risk factor for cardiomyopathy,
but there are other risk modifiers.
So
whether the patient receives chest radiation, the young age at the time of cancer
diagnosis, female sex, other comorbidities like
hypertension, obesity, those can really impact this outcome.
And as you can see that there's a direct dose response relationship
between anthracyclines and the risk of cardiomyopathy, and that risk really
starts declaring itself once you receive about 100 to
150 milligrams per meter squared of
anthracyclines. And the mechanism in general is just
polygenic. It's also multiple mechanisms.
It's not just one mechanism that leads to the
anthracycline-mediated cardiomyopathy, and some of the mechanisms are just sort of
outlined on this figure here. And so whether it's from reactive oxygen
species production, DNA damage, the impact of
doxorubicin transports the metabolism of that drug,
interference with iron uptake, and/or
calcium handling, where you have accumulation of calcium
intracellularly and damage of sarcomere.
So those are all
mechanisms that kind of lend together to lead to
anthracycline-mediated cardiomyopathy.
So I think for this purposes of this brief presentation, what I'm going to
give you is just some snippets, how does some of these genes kind
of play into the different components of
that multi-mechanistic phenotype that we just discussed.
So the CBR3 gene is actually on chromosome 21.
It's expressed in the heart. It's more prevalent in Black individuals, and the
CBR3 gene is actually important for metabolism of
doxorubicin, particularly to the
toxic alcohol derivative is what actually causes toxicity to
the cardiac myocytes. And now individuals with the CBR3
GG variant, as shown here, actually show a marked increase
in anthracycline-mediated toxicity at much lower doses, what we would actually
consider low to medium doses of anthracycline.
And so having that information is actually important in terms of how we
would approach surveillance, what mechanisms
or what types of cardioprotection we would actually offer that patient more than
just azoroxene. So do we give these patients beta blockers?
Do we actually bring on ACE inhibitors?
So I think that that's important to kind of know the biology of the host and
that interaction with treatment.
And likewise, I think variations in the retinoic acid
receptor gamma is associated with
significant susceptibility to anthracycline mediated.
So it really kind of modifies
that susceptibility, and it's felt that
it actually
increases the expression of
TOP2B, and that really is the
culprit for increasing that susceptibility to anthracyclines.
And then finally, kind of having a better understanding of other genotypes, for
example, the SULT4 genotypes, so variations in that
SULT4 genotype really modifies the risk that
you can have with doses of anthracycline in terms of the
cardiotoxicity that you can see. And as shown here, individuals with the GG
genotype show marked susceptibility to anthracycline-mediated
toxicity.So these are some ways of really thinking about the
host and the environment, which is the treatment that you
give as part of the cancer that can kind of predispose to the dreaded outcome of
cardiomyopathy that can have significant
effects in terms of the survival for our patients, especially
even if they are able to overcome, and get
cured from their primary cancer.
So this is where I'm going to shift and give you a little bit more of an endocrine
heavier influence of survivorship, and hopefully this is something
that you can appreciate because I think these are really understudied
areas of
cancer survivorship that deserves more attention given their medical consequences.
So in an earlier work that we did with the childhood cancer survivor
study group, what we were able to show is that our survivors have more than twofold
risk of diabetes compared to their siblings.
And with some of the exposures being at least recognized and delineated,
so abdominal radiation is a known risk,
not surprisingly, you have direct damaging effects of that radiation on your beta
cells, and there's a linear dose-dependent increased risk for
diabetes, particularly with radiation to the tail of the pancreas.
But total body radiation is, to me, the more dreaded exposure.
So as an endocrinologist, when I see patients with TBI exposure, I really can
see that delineated increased risk for type 2 diabetes.
And some of that is just beyond the effect on the pancreas.
It's more the aberrations that you see in the body,
mass index, the increased total body adiposity, the increased visceral
adiposity, in addition to the sarcopenia, really sets these
patients up for reduced insulin sensitivity and risks for
diabetes.
But that alone is not the full picture.
So we do know that genetic ancestry also equally can change that
trajectory, and it's not just radiation alone, that affects that
risk. So in this study, what you can see here is that individuals with African
ancestry actually have marked increased risk with any alkylator
exposure, while in the
European ancestry that is predominantly seen with
really high doses of alkylators. So again, some of that is concomitant in
terms of different types of exposure, but the genetic ancestry actually plays a
role, and it can give us a window into addressing disparities in terms of the
outcomes and survivorship. And so early on in the paradigm that I
presented, I actually offered opportunities for
trials that can actually think about preventing some of these outcomes.
So this is a clinical trial that we recently submitted to the NIH and really
looking at patients that are at high risk exposures for
diabetes and focusing on insulin sensitivity by
introducing metformin and/or resistance training compared to just
regular lifestyle
counseling that we give in clinic to see how, with mechanistic
assessment of the beta cell, and kind of excursion of
glucose and fat after giving them an oral glucose tolerance
test, how these patients are able to improve their insulin
sensitivity.
So the other thing that for me as a pediatric endocrinologist is really important
is my patients' normal milestones.
So I think puberty is an important milestone that our pediatric patients need
to achieve.
And that to me is an area that is always difficult when a
parent looks at me and says, "Doc, they said that it's not going to be as big of a
deal. We really talked just about the fertility." And yet you have a 14
or a 15-year-old female who just has not gone through puberty with elevated
gonadotropins and undetectable
AMH. So I think that gonadotoxicity is not just fertility.
Fertility is very important, but the hormonal aspect of the gonads
are equally important. And some of the gonadotoxic regimens
are on this slide of what we typically think about.
I would add immunotherapy to that list because we're really learning about the
effects of immunotherapy. But some of the
granulosa cells of the ovary are very susceptible to the same
toxic mechanisms of gonadotoxic therapies on the
gonad. But gonadotoxic therapy alone is not the full
story. So again, there are patients that can have profound
gonadotoxicity, even with conventional small doses of
what we would say based on the typical risk factor charts that we have
should not, in all intents and purposes, have gonadotoxicity.
And that also is a study that we did with our colleagues, using the data
from St. Jude, is where if you have homozygosity at
this haplotype at chromosome four, you actually really show a marked
increased susceptibility for premature ovarian insufficiency.
And what we can see is using the St. Jude life data, so where you have actually
more laboratory information to confirm
the outcome of interest. So even with small doses of alkylators, the risk
of POI or premature ovarian insufficiency is sixfold
higher. But if these patients actually get even small doses of radiation, that
risk goes up to 26-fold higher. So again, your genotype
actually will matter in terms of those outcomes.
So what I'm going to do is essentially now shift to giving you a different frame
model, what we can think about bringing in different thought
processes from survivorship, rather than just thinking of the epidemiology and
the descriptive models. I think we need to start thinking about the biology of
survivorship. And the epigenetic accelerated aging is a
nice conceptual framework for us to think about.
So for those of you who are uninitiated in this topic, so the
epigenetic accelerated aging is basically your biological age minus your
chronological age, but it's a really nice way for us to integrate the cancer
therapy with the patient's genetics, and then more importantly, with the
interactions with the environment.
So we know that there is a mechanistic basis where you actually can get
persistent DNA methylation changes, and this epigenetic
dysregulation is essentially what is going to be driving some of these aging
phenotypes. And so, earlier studies that have been done, again,
this is an area that really deserves further attention.
Earlier studies have really shown that this
epigenetic accelerated aging
is much higher in survivors compared to controls, and it actually
correlates with some of the outcomes like cardiometabolic disease, frailty, and
mortality. So again, it's a nice way to think
aboutTo harness as a framework,
particularly in our patients, and use that because it
is detectable even early after therapy.
And that alone, I think we need to think about the modifiers, what are the genetic
variations, the lifestyle factors, again, physical activity versus sedentary
lifestyles, the social determinants, again, what environmental exposures
the patient has. And then this can be used for
clinical implications because it allows us to basically
provide our patients with opportunities to deliver precision risk
stratification. We can identify our high-risk survivors much earlier and
then kind of give them informed, targeted lifestyles and pharmacologic
interventions. So in a way, it really operationalizes the
link between exposure, biology, and long-term
outcomes.
And finally, just again to remind you why hormones actually are important, I think
the concept of estrogen deficiency is really an underappreciated
late effect in our patients. And I think, again, kind of
overall, this figure shows some of the important impacts that
estrogen deficiency can have on a lot of organ systems, but our survivors
come to the equation already with risks for
cardiovascular defects based on the anthracycline,
let's say, radiation exposures, musculoskeletal deficits from the cancer
therapy. So a lot of these areas are already
impacted, so what we don't know is the effects of estrogen deficiency in this
patient population. And so recently, one of our
talented investigators at CHOP, Dr.
Pollack, was
just awarded an ASCO Young Investigator Award to really look at that effect of
estrogen deficiency in our female survivors and the role of
HRT or hormone replacement therapy in modulating that.
So I think that that's going to be exciting data that we can look
into. And so finally, I think we are reaching a point where hopefully I
can persuade you that we need to shift gears.
We need to really change our lens. So looking at survivorship
2.0, to me, is not sufficient. Looking at just five-year overall
survival is not the right metric. It's really static, and I think we need
to really step out of that approach where we think of survivorship as a static
phase, and it's not just the period that starts post-treatment.
Really, survivorship to me, and hopefully you have been persuaded enough,
at least based on some of the information that I shared, that it's really an
evolving biology that's shaped with the cancer therapy,
but the patient's genetic background and the environment that they're
exposed.
And so really, this slide is kind of bringing a lot of the concepts together.
So the top portion of the slide is really highlighting what is our current models
of what I have at least termed as survivorship 2.0.
So remember that this is very
organ based, what exposure you got, let's do
surveillance on that organ, and once we identify an abnormality, then we're going
to address that. We have generalized care plans.
These are not personalized, and our patients really aren't engaged as
much, which is why we have a lot of loss to follow up during transition.
And then we really need to change how we advocate, especially at the policy
level, because if the only metric that we're using is the five-year overall
survival, what we're really missing is that price tag that's coming with
respect to survivorship and how that's affecting the health outcome for our
patients. And so really with all of that, we should start bringing a lot
of the oncology mindset to even the world of survivorship.
Think about how potentially we could use ctDNA for even looking at
surveillance for some of these outcomes to really think about more
targeted therapy, engaging our patients according to their
risk status, and making sure that they have access to healthcare.
And then finally, what I want to leave you with is what I think is the
right paradigm. We need to really think about
survivorship really as a precision care that's
across lifespan. We have rituals where you
actually complete cancer therapy, you ring a bell, and that's when we
actually want to think about the period of survivorship.
But I argue that survivorship actually is just the
beginning of with the biology. It's just the beginning where this
new trajectory is defined by what is the patient's genetics, the
therapy that they have received, and what environment they are in to kind of
allow us to better predict what negative
outcomes that they're going to have at a much earlier time point where we can
then treat those to mitigate some of these
unwanted clinical outcomes. So in a way, really, survivorship is
more of a dynamic biological state and not just an
endpoint. So with that, I thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to
answer any questions.
I'll just start off and just thank you for the talk because I don't think we've
ever had one like that at ACR, and the idea of bringing more science to
survivorship, I'd love to see what the session's like in 10
years and then look back and see what progress we've made.
So I guess my brief question is, you mentioned some
germline variants that might be predictive of outcomes
in terms of long-term toxicities and things like that.
Have you seen people adopt that in practice?
Are people actually
doing that genetic profiling and looking for those alterations?
I have not seen that become standard of care.
I think a lot of it is also with the challenges of coverage.
So I think for the purposes right now, at least we have established a
paradigm where this is the genetic that's going to affect how we're going to treat
the cancer, so therefore, you can make an argument.
But from a survivorship aspect, that just has not been proven.
And everyone says, "Oh, that's a great model for the future." But to me,
I think that this is where it would be nice at the time of diagnosis, even before
you give any therapies, you know what is the genetic makeup of your patients,
what are the risk factors. These are the genes that puts the patient at risk
for autotoxicity or cardiomyopathy, and with that,
you not only tailor the cancer therapy, but you actually bring in the
prevention for the late effects at the time of your cancer treatment.
You have a question?
Yes. Thank you, first of all. But I wanted to get your opinion on how
we can improve communicating these long-term effects to pediatric
patients while also preserving their right to assent and autonomy.
So I think that's a really good question.
Where I have struggled, or I think is really hard for parents, and they communicate
that, and then especially then patients can also verbalize that, is
that there is really this period of you're with your oncologist, they're holding
your hand, they're with you throughout, and then all of a sudden we say, "Okay,
you've met the metric. You need to now transition to survivorship." And that's a
very abrupt change for parents. A lot of times they feel like they just
sort of were left alone, and they enter survivorship, and all of a sudden they feel
flooded with it's this late effect, and it's this problem, and a lot of
it may be new because a lot of the surveillance has not happened.
So I would argue that there needs to be collaboration of
care with survivorship physicians early on with the oncologist.
So I think the knowledge has increased so much that you cannot just expect
the oncologist to remember all the details of therapy and, oh, by the way, make
sure that you are also doing the surveillance.
So I think that that to me is the appropriate approach in
engaging the patients, and if they see that this is patient-centric, that really
pertains to them, hopefully that can really change the equation in terms of
empowering them and putting them in the driver's seat.
Okay, great.
Okay, so I'm going to finish off the session.
I don't work on survivorship, and I also am not a doctor who
takes care of young onset patients.
I think I was asked to chair this session because I'm a parent of a young
onset cancer survivor. And so for me, what can I bring to the
table? And I'm going to talk about our institutional efforts
really to genomically profile every patient.
I think, at least in my view, patients with rare cancers get left
behind because there isn't dedicated programs or fundings for their cancer
type. And I think our strategy has been to bring those patients into
our institutional scale efforts so that everybody's getting profiled and
that when we are testing new drugs, that rare cancers are part of that.
And here's my disclosures. So I've been at Sloan Kettering now 28 years.
I arrived in 1998,
and I think we've come a long way, and we've got a long way to go.
But when I arrived, there was actually no approved targeted therapies.
Herceptin was approved shortly thereafter.
We hadn't actually completed the Human Genome Project.
The first draft came out in 2001, and actually we had no genomic
sequencing core at Sloan Kettering.
So we didn't even have the ability to, in a easy way, molecularly
profile our patients. And so we've made progress, but progress has been
uneven, and many patients don't benefit from precision oncology, and
it's extremely difficult to get rare cancers involved in those
programs, and we've tried to come up with strategies to be more
inclusive. So what was really the guiding principles for me as I
created our genomic profiling efforts?
Really just three quick anecdotes from early in my career.
One was the discovery of BRAF as mutated in human cancer,
and this was a pan-cancer effort. What was done here by the Sanger
Institute, this was back in 2002, it was published in
"Nature," is they took a pan-cancer set of tumor
samples, and they used the best technology they had at the time, which was Sanger
sequencing, and they sequenced all the genes in the MAP kinase pathway, and it was
a low-risk effort because we knew there was RAS mutations in human cancer, so we're
going to at least better characterize where those were found.
And really just with this fishing expedition type of effort, they
identified BRAF as being mutated in human cancer.
And then it took us nine years from that discovery to develop a
selective inhibitor of RAF, which then initially worked in melanoma
patients and then turned out to be effective pan-cancer.
So at least the lesson from this experience was it was becoming
possible, really for the first time, that we could sequence all genes in
all patients and really understand that genomic landscape across
all cancer types.
The second really story that sort of shaped the creation of our
genomic efforts was our effort to look at exceptional
responder outliers. And so really what this effort was is we were taking
patients who were on clinical trials that failed, but
inevitably, there was always one or two patients on those studies that actually
responded and did well, but we didn't understand why.
And this was just an example of that.
This was a 70-year-old woman with metastatic bladder cancer, and she was treated
with a drug called everolimus, which had been approved shortly before then in
kidney cancer. And anytime a new drug was approved back then in any cancer, we
tried it in every other cancer for a lack of better ideas.
And so we tried it in bladder cancer. We treated 45 patients.
Only two responded.
But the two that responded really caught our imagination.
One of those patients actually responded for over 10 years, and the
question is why? So we started to study that cancer.
We did targeted sequencing efforts and really couldn't find anything, and really
were bailed out by technology. We actually performed the first whole genome
sequence at Sloan Kettering in this patient with an exceptional response.
To my knowledge, this was the first whole genome sequencing of a bladder cancer
done anywhere. And what we found was concurrent mutations in
TSC1 and NF2. The reason that those were interesting is
that loss of function of those mutations led to activation of
TORC1, which is the direct target of everolimus.
So in retrospect, this patient was the perfect candidate for everolimus.
We just didn't know it going into the clinical trial.
We weren't using genomics to stratify enrollment.
But one could imagine that if we could know the genomic status of every single one
of our patients, we could design clinical trials different, and we could have
greater success by putting on those patients most likely to respond
based upon their genomic
profile.The second effort was just many family
members. This is just one of my family members, which was a young woman with
high-risk stage three breast cancer,
who underwent a bilateral mastectomy, chemotherapy, hormones.
Unfortunately, after five years, her cancer recurred, and
she had very limited genomic profiling to look for risk factors.
Just BRCA1, BRCA2, and CHEK2 was all that was standard back
then. But the question is, could we incorporate into our emerging
genomic profiling efforts, our institutional efforts, not just tumor
sequencing, but paired germline sequencing to identify
which patients had a heritable cancer risk?
And could we do that
at institutional scale? So that was really the mission statement for the Kravis
Center for Molecular Oncology, which we created in
2014. Our efforts were to define the
molecular drivers in every patient, facilitate enrollment onto clinical trials of
targeted therapies, now more recently, immunotherapies and cellular therapies,
and really identify germline variants that contributed to cancer
initiation and foster translational science.
And the hope here was that we could do this for every patient, not just common
cancers, but for rare cancers as well.
So to be able to do that, we actually needed three things.
One is we need to actually write a clinical trial because
back in 2014, it wasn't standard of care to do this type
of molecular profiling for most patients, and that trial was called
12245. The primary goal was for every patient coming
to Sloan Kettering to do a tumor molecular profile.
But our secondary goal was to do a germline genetic profile.
So we really came up with a tumor normal paired assay that would allow us to look
for both. And then we also got consent for research studies, and we sort of
future-proofed that, so we could do future
research analyses using platforms that hadn't even been
discovered, like spatial transcriptomics or single-cell
sequencing. The other thing we needed was a clinical test, and our
test at Memorial has been MSK Impact.
We've now gone through four versions of this, where we've slowly increased the
number of genes. Our current panel looks at 505 genes.
And again, we take DNA from both the tumor and the normal, which allows us to look
for germline heritability as well as tumor somatic mutations.
And we actually have a whole exome sequencing version in process called
Impact X, which we hope to launch in the next two years, which will
finally expand this out to all genes.
So we also wanted to be able to share the data.
We knew that if we constricted this data to a small number of investigators, its
impact would be small. So we got permission to share this
data, initially in a HIPAA-compliant way through cBioPortal.
And I took this screenshot just a few days ago showing that
we've now sequenced over 109,000 patients'
tumor samples, 162,000 samples in
total. And actually, this is a young onset session.
By doing this at an institutional scale, we probably have one of the larger data
sets of young onset tumors. So if you look at the number
of patients in our cohort that are 40 or younger, we're now over 10,000
patients, of whom
72% are alive, but 27.4% have already died
of their disease. So clearly, we need new drugs, and this is a clear
unmet need. So I knew Kathy would mention this paper, so I'm not going to
spend much time on it. But the first cancer we actually looked at was
young onset colon cancer in terms of early onset.
Were the genetics of early onset tumors different than the genetics of
average onset patients? And you can see it was a very collaborative
effort given the number of authors, and this was published back in 2021
in JNCI, and we really didn't see much.
So this is comparing the frequency of a particular mutation in average onset.
This is early onset. And you can see pretty much all the common genes
really lie along that 45-degree axis, showing not much different.
And we actually didn't see
differences in outcome in early onset
colon cancer versus later onset colon cancer, at least in our
cohort. We did see a higher frequency in young onset patients
in germline alterations that are associated with increased
heritable risk. But we saw pretty significant frequency of these same germline
alterations in average or late onset tumors.
So at least it's been our recommendation for a number of years now to do
germline genetic testing in all patients, and that age really shouldn't
guide whether that testing is done.
And I think that's been slow to get different expert
consensus adoption, but I think that's where we're going, hopefully, in the
near future. And clearly, there's issues of our young onset patients worrying about
future insurance coverage and is this going to be considered a
preexisting condition that makes them a little more anxious to do
that. More recently, we've done the same analysis in bladder cancer, and it
actually turned out to be a little more interesting than it was in colorectal
cancer. So we did find some genes that were different
in early onset cancer versus later onset cancer.
For example, HRAS mutations are much more common in
patients with bladder cancer who are diagnosed at an age less than
45. Similarly with CDKN2A, suggesting that the drug
targets that we're potentially going to go after might be a little bit different.
They're not completely different.
I think we're seeing differences in the frequency, but that the spectrum
of somatic mutations might be a little bit different in early onset versus
later onset bladder cancer. And then similarly, again, we see
a higher frequency of
pathogenic or likely pathogenic germline alterations in young onset
patients than older onset patients, but not that much of a difference, suggesting
that essentially patients of any age with cancer of the bladder
should probably be getting germline testing.
The most notable thing about this project, this is still unpublished, was we
actually had several casesWhere we identified somatic
mosaicism in patients who had either
multiple cancers during their lifetime.
This is a 27-year-old patient who had not just bladder cancer, but a
thyroid tumor, desmoid tumor. And we
identified a somatic mosaic ERCC2
mutation in this patient. Not something they inherited from their parents, but
something that was present in some of their cancer cells and not in others.
And then similarly, here was a patient with a somatic mosaic ATRX mutation
that was present in all of the patients, what we thought were actually multiple
primary lesions within the bladder, but was also detectable in the blood,
suggesting that this was not simply a
somatic mutation only, but not present in other
normal tissues that we sampled from this patient.
So this concept of somatic mosaicism is something we've seen across other patients.
It's not that common. We see it, for example, in retinoblastoma, that not
every patient with retinoblastoma inherited it from a parent.
Sometimes it's a new onset alteration, and sometimes it's somatic mosaic.
So we also wanted to use this
genomic data to drive clinical trial enrollment.
Initially, we were hoping to do that using off-label therapies.
This is just one successful example of that.
This was a patient with melanoma
of Alex Shishari, who's one of our melanoma specialists, who
turned out to have very high-level HER2 amplification.
This was an acral melanoma patient, really very low mutation rate in these tumors,
but they have copy number driven tumors.
And it's not standard care to give a HER2 inhibitor in this patient, but the
patient had progressed on standard immunotherapy, and
Alex in particular, was able to get this patient trastuzumab
irinotecan, it's TDM-1,
which is FDA approved in breast cancer.
And you can see the patient's tumor here was in the lung
area, and this was a giant pleural effusion the patient had developed.
And within eight months, this patient went on to have a durable, complete response.
So we knew that we could repurpose drugs from one cancer type to another
in some cases. It doesn't always work, but in some cases.
But the challenge here is that it's very hard to get insurance companies to
give you these drugs as off-label.
And that was really the inspiration for our basket
trial program, which we
started back in 2013. And really what a basket trial is, is instead of
having a trial of a novel drug that's disease focused,
you open up that trial where anyone's eligible as long as they have the right
mutational status, and it doesn't matter what kind of cancer they had.
So this was a study I led as the international PI of neratinib, which is
a HER2 inhibitor, where any patient with a HER2 mutation was
eligible for the study. And we put in different arms,
hence the term basket study different baskets for particular
diseases where we know HER2 mutations might be present, for example,
bladder cancer, colon cancer, endometrial cancer, et cetera.
But we always put in another arm into these studies because we sometimes
see rare cancer patients show up with a disease type that we
haven't even previously known had that particular mutation type.
And by making them eligible for these kind of trials, we
essentially had, I think, a greater impact on rare cancers with these studies
than the more common cancers, where it's quite easy to get a company to do, for
example, one study in breast cancer and colon cancer, but not so easy to get
that trial in bladder cancer or ovarian cancer, even more
rare cancers than that. And we saw some pretty
interesting results on this study.
This was a patient with breast cancer who would've been considered back
in 2015 as HER2 normal because they didn't have
HER2 overexpression by IHC or gene amplification by
FISH. But by NGS, the patient had a mutation V77L in
the kinase domain of HER2, similar to the L858R
EGFR mutation. This patient had been through eight prior systemic therapies, the
last four of which she didn't respond to at all and went on to have a complete
response to neratinib. But what we found with neratinib was that disease
type really mattered. So we saw pretty reasonable results
in breast cancer. About half of the patients responded, but none of the colon
cancer patients responded. Some of the lung cancer patients responded.
But for example, in bladder cancer, the results were
kind of disappointing. So really why is this?
I think we figured this out in part.
In one part, this is due to the fact that the type of mutation you see in
HER2 differs as a function of the type of cancer.
So, the mutation that is pharmacologically most
sensitive to neratinib is these kinase domain
hotspot mutations, and those are actually most common in breast cancer.
And that explains in part the greater activity in breast cancer versus, say,
bladder cancer, where most of the patients with HER2 mutation have an
extracellular domain mutation that induces kinase
activation through dimer formation,
and thus are less sensitive to neratinib.
In the case of the colorectal cancer patients, it's due in part due to co-mutation
pattern. A lot of the HER2 mutant colorectals have KRAS
co-mutation, and unless you address that mutation as well,
neratinib is going to prove to be ineffective.
And we think some of the other heterogeneity here is due to lineage
specific differences in epigenetic programming that hasn't really been
fully elucidated.
But we have seen examples where the activity of these
targeted therapies is sufficient pan-cancer to lead to what's called a
tumor-agnostic FDA authorization.
The first for a kinase inhibitor was larotrectinib, based upon the basket study of
that drug. But more recently, we've seen this with BRAF V600E, RET
fusions, MSI, TMB, and then for immunohistochemistry,
3+ HER2 with trastuzumab deruxtecan,
which is an ADC. So we've definitely made progress, but there's still a
significant unmet need.So where are we going?
We're trying to do broader sequencing.
And one thing that we do know is that DNA sequencing has its limits.
It doesn't tell you everything you need to know about the biology of a
patient's tumor, and this is just one example of that.
This is a patient with melanoma who was resistant to immunotherapy.
We ran MSK-Impact looking at our 500 or so genes and found
no driver. We then ran whole exome and still found no
driver in this patient, and then ran a targeted RNA-Seq assay called
Archer, where we found a ETV6-NTRK3 fusion.
I think this is the first time we had ever seen an NTRK fusion in a patient
with melanoma. And luckily, we had a basket study for that
exact drug,
mutation combination of LOXO-101, which is now called
larotrectinib, and you can see this patient went on to have a pretty impressive
response. But again, DNA sequencing is still not telling us
everything we need to know. So our efforts are really focused on RNA
sequencing
to get more information. In particular, we haven't found DNA sequencing to be
particularly useful in figuring out who's going to respond to
immunotherapies or ADCs
or other non-kinase inhibitor therapies.
And we've now run about 1,000 patients on our assay.
It's called MSK-Target. I'm just going to give you two examples of what that data
could look like in the future. This is an example where we're
showing HER2 expression by RNA sequencing across tumor
types, and you can see that there are some patients with various tumor types that
have very high levels of HER2 expression.
And for example, here's one in lung cancer, and this patient did go on to have an
exceptional response to trastuzumab deruxtecan.
So our goal was not to do this for HER2 because a lot of patients get HER2 IHC
already, but to do this for other novel targets,
where we'll be able to enrich enrollment onto clinical trials based
upon their RNA-Seq profile. This is an example where a patient came in with
lung cancer, and the red dot is the current patient, and the
gray dots are all the patients with lung cancer that came before this patient.
And you can see they have very high levels of HER2 expression, high levels of
tissue factor. There's ADCs against tissue factor in clinical development,
low level of DL3. So this, we hope, is going to allow us to enrich
clinical trials of ADC cellular therapies, in particular for
patients with rare cancers, by having basket studies that are
driven by RNA expression, not by gene mutation as we've done in the
past, but by RNA expression of novel ADCs.
And we could do that pan-cancer and hopefully have an impact on patients
with young adult cancers where these trials are hard to do.
We tried to do a lot of outreach outside of MSK.
If we believe the statement that the best cancer care is going to
require molecular profiling, patients who don't have
access to that molecular profiling may not get the best cancer care.
This was an effort really funded by my wife more than anyone, based upon our
daughter's story
with a rare cancer, where we offer free genetic testing to anyone in the world
with select
rare cancers, either because we wanted to learn about those rare cancers or because
we had a drug that we knew would work, but the patients weren't necessarily getting
the genetic testing. And just one of those examples was called mammary secretory
carcinoma of the breast. This is a tumor that arises
in either prepubescent women or girls or
young women, and we knew this was interesting because generally this is
associated with having an NTRK fusion.
So we put out a call through social media for anyone in the world with
a mammary secretory carcinoma of the breast, and if
they had that, we would be happy to sequence their tumor free
of charge through this Make an Impact program. And I'll just show you one example.
This was a girl in Bangladesh.
This is actually her third recurrence, but she was initially diagnosed with
a small tumor in her chest,
which was this prepubescent breast cancer. They cut it out.
Unfortunately, it came back. They cut it out again. It came back again.
And this is a few months after that
last recurrence, showing that she had this fungating tumor in her
chest. And
we heard about this patient through social media outreach.
We're able to get the tumor sent over from Bangladesh.
We're able to sequence the tumor, confirm that she had an NTRK
fusion. And I think even more miraculously, David Hyman and Neil
Shukla were actually able to convince the company that was developing
the NTRK inhibitor to fly that patient over to New York from Bangladesh,
put them up at the Ronald McDonald House, and then we did a single-patient
IND exception for LOXO-101, and this is just after three weeks of
treatment. So one can imagine if we could do this for a patient in Bangladesh,
hopefully we can do this to patients in New York who are not getting molecular
testing. And our hope is to reopen this program.
We've kind of put it on hold temporarily because, to me, most patients should get
standard of care molecular testing, and we're kind of holding back our
philanthropic dollars for what's next, and that's RNA sequencing.
We're hoping to offer a similar program that if there's an ADC
disease association where we think people are not getting that drug because
they're not getting the right testing, can we do this social media outreach again?
And just to show another successful example, this was a rare
cancer called histiocytosis that young patients usually get.
It's a blood cancer. And why this was interesting is that a
lot of these patients have BRAP V600E mutations or other targetable
alterations in the MAP kinase pathway, and this is just an example of one of those
patients, and you can see all these tumors on his back.
This patient was from Spain, and you can see after just three months of the MEK
inhibitor, the patient had this dramatic response.
And actually, all but one patient on this trial
responded, and all but two actually have had durable responses
without progression on targeted therapy with the mean age of this
cohort being 31, and it's probably only about 700 patients in the whole
world with this cancer type who actually require therapy.
So not a study you can really do at one institution, a study where you really need
sort of universal outreach to be able to accomplish this.
So I'm going to leave my talk here and just sort of
summarize that our strategy for rare young adult cancers...
is to really advocate for their inclusion in all of our population
scale efforts and tumor agnostic efforts.
One of the early things that David Hyman was able to do when he was still at
Memorial was actually reduce the
age
eligibility from 18 to 12 for essentially all
of our studies. It's still hard to get the really little pediatric kids onto these
studies because sometimes they can't even swallow pills.
But why shouldn't a 17-year-old be able to go on a clinical
trial for adults? They're adult size, they can swallow
pills. And so we did that early on. Again,
DNA-based molecular profiling really hasn't identified huge differences in
somatic mutational profile between young and average onset.
But my hope is that RNA sequencing is going to tell us more.
So we're really interested in that question as our cohort gets
bigger with RNA sequencing. I think the social media
outreach efforts are underutilized, especially for patients
with rare cancers. And to me, germline testing should be universal, not
age-based.
And hopefully we can convince the payers and
really things like NCCN that that really should be the case.
And so I'll just thank everyone at the institution who's been involved with this
effort. I'm very privileged to
co-lead it, but it really takes a whole institution to do this.
And just thanking AACR for actually having a survivorship young
onset session for the first time, and hopefully this will be something that they
continue in future years. So thank you all for coming.
Happy to answer any questions if there are any, or we can do it afterwards
if there's at least one question.
This stool's a little weird here because it's making me too high, but I'm not that
tall, okay?
Thanks for a really great talk, and I agree with a lot of your opinions
on what should be standard of care.
Yeah.
And I really like what you guys are doing in terms of the RNA seq.
And with the cost of that coming down, it's
so low now, it's very practical.
But as I think you know
50% of the time it's wrong, and 50% of the time
it tends to under-predict if you're
looking for IO targets because there's so many post-transcriptional
mechanisms of protein overexpression.
So are you guys thinking about mass spec
not tomorrow, but is that down the road, and
is proteomics really what we should be doing in thinking about what are
the right IO targets?
So I completely agree with you. At some point, my mentor was Neil Rosen, and
Neil was a big believer that we don't actually target the RNA, we're targeting the
protein, and so he would 100% agree with you.
I think it's just, what can we do next?
I think we want to do all of these things, and I think for us, we've just sort of
come to the belief that RNA, if we actually layer it on top of DNA at the
time we're doing the DNA sequencing, that it's not that
expensive, that actually most of the cost for us to do molecular profiling now is
not the sequencing anymore.
It's actually the
path review, macro dissection, DNA extraction, and
then maybe the computational stuff on the back end.
And so I think RNA, it's the right time because, as you said, the costs have
come down. If we do DNA, we're doing most of the costs already, and maybe it's only
going to be a few hundred more dollars to do RNA, and we've been able to put
together some philanthropic funding to do about 5,000 patients to get this
going, and hopefully we can show it's useful.
But I think that's the next step, and then
proteomics, if we can scale it.
It took us about 10 years to get the RNA to the point,
and we're using a capture-based approach, so we're not going to get everything.
We're going to miss out on some microRNAs and some long non-coding
RNAs with the approach we're using, but we needed to come up with an approach that
worked on most of the paraffin that we had,
because that's the reality of the type of tissue we have.
I agree completely. We're technically not there, but we will be there, and
sensitivity of these latest generation of mass spectrometers are so
great. So I think this is what the iteration we're just going to have to-
I'll just throw out there that I think one of the worries I have is that academia
is a
declining presence in this space because the companies...
This is a reasonable send out type of thing.
High volume leads to economies of scale and better turnaround time if you're
running more samples. And many academic institutions, even the large ones, have
sort of given up on trying to do a lot of this and are sending it out to the
companies. I think having academia involved in these molecular profiling
efforts is going to be important so we can push innovation and
actually really understand what the data means. Yeah.
Hey there. I'm not a scientist, so this is a super basic,
quick question.
I noticed different ages for where you were based on
cancer type, about young onset.
Is there a definition or does it actually-
Maybe Kathy can take this question because there is no definition for every cancer.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think it varies. I'm sure you can attest to this as well.
It varies if you're looking at AYA literature versus
young onset versus adolescent young onset, and so
at our institution, we just made it anybody that was less than 50.
And a lot of literature does include that, but if you look at a lot of AYA
literature, it's sometimes less than 35 or less than 40.
But it's a very important question.
Yeah. No. Thank you.
We tried to use standard deviation type cutoffs, but
there isn't any one perfect cutoff probably. Yeah.
Hi. Thanks for the great presentation. I'm Felicia from AstraZeneca.
Also not a scientist. I work on the public policy side, so really
appreciate your point about readying payers for this kind of stuff.
My question is about regulators.
Have you engaged in any discussions with them?
Do you have any views on N numbers for basket trials and
what we should be requiring?
So the interesting thing when we launched the basket trial program at Sloan
Kettering was not the regulators being resistant.
It was actually the doctors and the investigators.
I still remember presenting the first basket study that we opened up at Sloan
Kettering. It was a BRAF vemurafenib study that Dave Hyman ultimately took
over. Jose Baselga was the international PI.
And one of the comments we got about the study is from a very senior
lymphoma doctor saying, "I hate this study.
It's a fellow killer." And I could not,
for the life of me, figure out what the hell he was talking about.
We're not killing any fellows here, so I'm not really sure what this is.
But what he was saying was that instead of having 20 different clinical
trials for each cancer and the fellow could be first author because they
were small studies, this one giganto study would probably be
first author, senior person, and that would not be good for the fellows.
And I looked at them and I'm like, "We're not doing this for the fellows.
We're trying to come up with a more efficient way to do clinical trials."
And he was right in a sense. The niraparib study enrolled over
500 patients. It was just a study that kept going because we would
see, for example, in breast cancer, response rate looked pretty good.
And then the company actually came back to us and said, "Well, why don't we open up
another arm in breast cancer for Herceptin plus niraparib?" And we did that trial.
So it turned out to be very efficient.
The FDA and Rick Klausner just visited Sloan Kettering recently, actually was
very excited about basket studies.
What happened is some of the companies, not necessarily AstraZeneca, I'm not going
to accuse you guys. But some of the companies were like, "Oh, the FDA will never
agree to that." And the FDA actually loved the idea from day one.
But the doctors were a little reluctant.
Some industry was reluctant, but I think it's proven itself.
Peak basket study, I think we're already past it a little bit, to be honest with
you. And I think the larotrectinib and the MSI studies
were peak basket trial. But we can do new types of
basket studies for cellular therapies, ADCs, bispecifics, but we
need new diagnostic platforms. It's not going to be based upon probably DNA
mutations. It's going to be based upon either RNA sequencing or
proteomics or some other epigenetic profiling.
But I think the FDA, hopefully, Rick is, I guess, stepping down,
is still going to be open to that kind of idea.
And
really, it was the rare cancers that benefited. Histiocytosis was an early example.
And I still remember giving a talk, I think it was at NYU, when we had
one histiocytosis patient had responded.
And usually, you're not supposed to talk a lot about preliminary clinical trial
results, which I disagree with.
And we presented that one case. It was a patient who had brain involvement of
histiocytosis, went on to have a complete response.
And I would literally say within a month of presenting that case,
every histiocytosis patient in the world seemed to know about that result
through social media, and then it drove incredible enrollment
onto the clinical trial. The patients were looking out for the clinical trial.
And in the end, that basket study enrolled 20, 30 patients with histiocytosis.
And actually led to FDA approval for vemurafenib
in Erdheim-Chester. So I don't think it's the regulators.
I think in some ways, it was the doctors saying, "Ah, it's not the way we always
did it. That's not
right. That's not the way you do these trials." So,
okay. So thank you everyone for coming. Okay.